just Justin gaiety versus Alex
wilkinowsky makes sense if I'm just
engaging I'd rather take a big name
fight and vocal knots get 55 then uh
Darius or something like that
now
Brandon
good morning in Vietnam name the movie
Good morning Vietnam who's in it Robin
Williams there we go come on ding ding
ding we're off to a good start Monday
morning July 30 31st 31st 31st baby
woppenheimer daddy
I got a Whopper last weekend whenever
Jay Big Jay shot my older brother's in
town uh we were born and raised on
Burger King there's one like a mile from
our house so it's how we used to eat is
Burger King so me and him dude he gets
here we some Oppenheimer Brothers man we
get one Whopper cheese and ketchup only
each and a large Diet Coke we don't [__]
with the fries don't miss any other
stuff that's all you get best burger in
town crushes anything else dude maybe
it's just a nostalgic Factor there's not
a ton of Burger Kings out there they're
closing up shop
it's like Blockbuster of burgers but it
is my favorite burger you're not into
Mayo what you're not into Mayo nah man
I'm American bro that's what makes the
Whopper for me no oh I like the lettuce
and all that lettuce and ketchup oh
sorry the Mayo and the ketchup no no I I
can't vouch for that okay all right it's
just ketchup cheese
that's it Fantastic Burger
what's Burgers uh
have it your way you rule that's the
campaign you rule my kids sing it all
the time that's why not you rule uh
fresh off a fun weekend kiddos a hell of
a weekend for just the fight fans in
general the fight business was a Boomin
it had a banger you had UFC 291 which
will jump right into you had uh Errol
Spence versus Bud Crawford go down as
well kind of the same time
um you had the cowboy Spike pan with Ben
Davis and Bradley Martin uh Ben Davis
man kid did very well for his first one
didn't he he's fun definitely have him
back that kid is fun when he took off
that second turtleneck
yeah he's a funny dude he's funny he's
good time does stuff so I'll definitely
have him back he was a great time kid
can drink some modellas huh
my God that dude downed just on air what
eight of them and then did he hang out
after one like when we rap everyone kind
of chills out I just don't hang out too
long I leave he was like I'm just gonna
chill and finish these Bears I was like
you're so 23.
he just finished those modellas man he's
chilled
yeah he's just down him good for him
he's a young kid from ASU doing the damn
thing grinding respect the hustle just a
good dude great time Bradley Martin was
in studio uh
uh it you know with the whole Mighty
Mouse thing and Bradley Martin it's not
like um Don King in this thing I think
Buddy elbow posted Brent shop setting up
Bradley Martin verse Mighty Mouse uh
match not literally they're both my
friends
Mighty Mouse uh restored the Bradley
talking about it and then uh I hit up
mighty I'm like hey Brad's good dude
that's my boy he's like yeah I'm down to
Grapple him I was a guy let me know
Brad's down I'm sure I'll pay for
whatever to fly you out and make it
happen but I can get some mats here at
my studio we can go to a real gym is it
going on vacation uh then you might have
something he said something August 11th
he's like but we'll figure it out I was
like all right cool that's it it's not
like I'm Dana White sending contracts
promoting this thing don't get twisted
it would be fun to watch I'll give him
that would be fun to watch but yeah
there's nothing more than that kiddos
um but yeah cowboy fight command was
funny if I haven't watched it available
right now I'm thinking boy YouTube and
then anywhere you listen to podcasts
available as well with the audio it's a
good one man uh watching UFC 291
Justin gaichi headlined by Justin gaichi
desampore in Salt Lake City Utah
um you know finished the same way very
similar to Leon Edwards and come on
Usman a little I know had kick KO so
there's comparison there and it's in the
same exact Arena same state so there's
no similarities it was opposite legs
setup was the same
um but the difference is Porey had his
hand up so he acknowledged the kick was
coming cabal didn't see the kick poor I
saw the kick hand was up and he still
got ko'd there so a little different but
I get the similarities Saturday night I
was not feeling it when they kept
comparing it and then I realized they
were both in Salt Lake City like that's
why they're running with this narrative
okay
um I thought just Gates really good I'll
tell you what
um you know I picked up some party to
win that fight like a lot of people did
um I don't think anyone predicted Justin
getji head kick KO it was brilliant
though why no one thought about that it
makes sense because Dustin pory was
doing a good job neutralizing the light
kicks if you're just in gaichi or his
coach like he knows he's gonna be
focused on the leg kicks let's go up top
I don't the writing was on the wall just
no one saw it before the fight so it
makes sense he went High because it
doesn't party still focus on
neutralizing those lower light kicks I
was having some success with it I gave
Dustin party the first round but I
thought it doesn't get you look good
he's definitely
um proved me wrong as far as when I go
you know Trevor Whitman just in case you
go I don't fight like I used to you know
I've changed my game I'm fighting
smarter but I still have that berserk in
Me by him fighting smarter 100 he showed
it on Saturday night he's fighting a lot
smarter a lot more calculated
um but and he does in spurt so do that
kind of crazed
um you know Wolverine Tasmanian Devil
burst every now and then but he it's
under control now and it showed in this
Dustin Poirier fight
um good fight overall I thought I
thought Porey did win the first round
and the obviously the second round the
head kick KO so I assume that third
one's coming down the road not
immediately next party's gonna be out of
wild Justin get you doesn't have really
a mark on him so I would assume
um based off what my friend chill Sonnen
is saying Chael sonen says
Charles Oliveira machev in October is
not happening because Charles Oliveira
is not going to fight him he's called
out you know uh Connor a few times he's
done some other stuff and as far as
cello says and tell usually knows what
the hell he's talking about he says the
Charles de levere is not going to make
that fight so I'd assume the UFC's on
the bat signal right now I'll see him if
Justin Gates is down to take that fight
otherwise if you're just engaging let's
say Charles does take the fight and her
uh Uncle Chael son is completely wrong
you just waited out there's nothing else
for you I posed you guys tell me what
you think about this and we should have
kg put this on my Instagram
um story but just Justin Gates even Alex
volkanovsky makes sense if Justin
doesn't want to wait now Justin is down
to wait Justin likes a lot of layoff
between his fights he's not a guy that
rushes into things he's actually more
about taking longer rests having a full
Camp
um so I'm assuming he's down to weight
and all he wants to be as a world
champion so that's all he cares about
not being Alex volkanovsky but outside
of a title shot which I think they're
going to give him but let's say they
don't outside that
you know the Darius fight doesn't make
sense coming off a loss
and just in case you so he's not only
he's coming off a loss he looked awful
and then also
Justin gaichi wants to fight for a title
they're taking him closer to the title
folkanovsky just it's a big fight big
fight volkanovski stock is higher than
ever after we did the yair I don't think
there's 145 around this planet that
could ever beat him in his prime I think
he's the best of all time there's not a
lot of 45 for volcanovski anymore
um and so if he does want to you know
kind of play with 55
fight just happened so it doesn't make a
ton of sense but I would watch it so
does he want to fight a guy like Justin
gate you I think he matches up really
well Justin gaichi I think it's a you
know it's a pay-per-view Main Event you
know so if the if Justin gaichi for
whatever reason the UFC doesn't offer
him that title shot right away there you
go you gotta get one more if I'm just
engagedy I'd rather take a big name
fight and vocal knots get 55 then uh
Darius or something like that because
outside Darius there's absolutely
nothing there's nothing for him so
that's why I put in the volkanovski
thing there
um Alex Pierre Jan bakovich the fans
lost in that one
I think the UFC kind of set them up for
failure a little bit just because they
put at altitude Alex Pierce first time
at 205 Jan's a big dude you know they're
not gonna have a ton of high output we
didn't get the fight we wanted to see
um this again in hindsight this had all
the riding on the wall there could be a
snooze Fest I would call it a snooze
Fest just not what we're expecting out
of these two John did stand and trade
with them I didn't have a problem with
oxpeare getting the decision
um first round I think some people might
have gave you on 10 8 and then you'd
give out to Pier the second and third
because that takedown the third wasn't
[__] it's late he didn't do anything
with it they don't really judge based
off just takedowns anymore like they did
back in the day I thought Alex was more
active y'all actually landed more head
shots but Alex's body and leg kicks
destroy all that so I think it's fair
that they gave Alex the win and I'm also
by someone else to win because now the
potential of him which I think is the
best fight in life have waited since Gus
Finn Jon Jones act Pierre Yuri is a
fight we need to see that that card
someone made I don't know if it was my
boy boss logic or one of the other
amazing artists on social media but had
a with oxpeare with like that the face
paint on that Warrior face paint and
then Yuri's face paint it was just their
two faces oh that is a fight man
Nothing's Gonna Be First Team all
violence they could do that for a BMF
title uh obviously it's gonna be for
world uh light heavyweight title but
that thing sign me take my money that
that is a fight and I and a corn Uncle
tail that's the fight the UFC wants big
Maynard is like that's the fight there's
gonna be no intern belts they don't do
intern belts anymore it's me aux Piera
versus Yuri for the light heavyweight
title that's supposed to be the fight
that's one of the best fights in a hot
second I want to see that so bad all
right fam let's take a little break from
chatting all things fight news because
time to take your shot at huge wins with
my friends at DraftKings Sportsbook you
could win big with money lines props
parlays and so much more right now new
customers can score 150 in bonus bets
instantly for betting just five dollars
on anything yet UFC Fight Night coming
up you got Corey sandahagan Rob font you
can watch the fight campaign on JRE with
Eddie Bravo Brian con myself that's this
Saturday in Austin Texas you can bet on
Nate Diaz Jake Paul it's all going down
yeah MLB popping right now
um but you know I like my UFC bets and
you got Nate Diaz Jake Paul you can bet
on all that stuff with my friends at
DraftKings again new customers can score
150 in bonus bets instantly for betting
just five dollars on anything download
the draftking Sportsbook app right now
use code shop show that's code shop show
only at DraftKings Sportsbook gambling
problem call 100 Gambler New York call
8778 Hope and why or text Hope and why
that's forcing 67369 in West Virginia
visit
www.1800 gambler.net in partnership with
Hollywood Casino at Charlestown Races
all games regulated by the West Virginia
Lottery please play responsibly in
Connecticut help is available for
problem gambling call
888-789-777 or visit
ccpg.org on behalf of Boot Hill Casino
Resort Kansas 21 or older in most
eligible States but age varies by
jurisdiction see draftkings.com
Sportsbook for details and
state-specific responsible gambling
resources bonus bets expire seven days
after issuance eligibility and deposit
restrictions apply terms at
sportsbook.draftkings.com baseball terms
DraftKings promo codes shop show Bros we
all know first impressions matter when
you're talking to the ladies or them
dudes out there and if you're not taking
care of your skin it's gonna be the
first thing that they see instantly they
either think you're way over older than
you are you got lines like the Grand
Canyon run down your face your forehead
or you just don't care about your
parents and that's not attractive show
them you do and make a great first
impression with Caldera Labs that's
right you're going to brush your teeth
today incorporating scaring skin care
steps before it you're guaranteed not to
mess up your routine leaving your breath
fresh and your face refreshed Caldera
lab creates high performance immense
gear skin care products and regiment
leads of product lineup a twice a day
routine to transform your skin Caldera
Labs no skin care world is heavily
heavily female driven has long been the
Wild Wild West for the Bros out there
why that's why they're making a solution
that's simple the regiment includes the
three products Clean Slate the base
layer and the good good that's right
Caldera lab icon Serum is what your boy
uses here so it doesn't look like I have
nothing off my face all right they got
you guys covered one minute in the
morning one at night and you're ready to
go you don't have that face like Clint
Eastwood all right so just for you guys
exclusive offer this is their best offer
available anywhere use code shop20
that's shab20 at calderilab that's
c-a-l-d-e-r-a-lab.com and you get 20 off
right now leave your fresh looking face
get rid of them not taking off the
bottom of your eyes you got wrinkles
like Clint Eastwood we got you man get
twinks off with code shop20 at
calderilab.com make Unforgettable First
Impressions and lead to the Charming
words you look so much younger 20% off
at calderilab.com with code shop20
Derek Lewis uh in delima
again this was my lock for win of the
week with Derek Lewis my boy who bets
insane amount of money on the fights is
the fight I told him they're close as a
dog you always want to bet on Derrick
Lewis because you knock anybody in the
world out but also his last fight on his
contract he's gotten he knows the stakes
he's got he got the best shape of his
life it's at altitude I think that was a
good booking because they're like Derek
Lewis if he knows he has time and he's
on his back foot doesn't he's not the
most exciting fighter but when he goes
he goes so good luck to dilemma in that
fight
um also another reason bet on Derek
Lewis he's not the main event there's no
pressure
this is the biggest of note here there's
no pressure so there's definitely no
pressure whereas the prelims and then
one boy falls out which rightfully so I
want to take the fight at 40 years old
so Wonder Boy falls out so they bump him
up to the third uh building on the main
card still not a ton of pressure that
third fight I've been in the third fight
I don't know four or three times in the
UFC those always like exciting
heavyweight fights they they want to
finish that you know you got the they
kick off the main card there's another
really competitive fight that third
one's kind of like entertaining and big
names might not be for a title title
implications but it's two big names and
they're expecting a finish and that's
why Derek Los got there so not a lot of
pressure Derek Lewis does his best work
when he's not under pressure Derek Lewis
Curtis blades is very similar where they
get as far as they can go and then
there's a mental block when there's all
the pressure on them it's you know
stylistic could be a tough match up and
it's they're one shot to win to get to
that title shot to get in the upper
echelon they always lose
just what it is and so for Derek Lewis
to have no pressure you're at altitude
last fight on his contract best shape of
his life so he took it serious he knows
what's at stake how could you not bet on
Derrick Lewis man that was the easy one
that was an easy one uh I think Bradley
Martin called it I think he said 42nd he
predicted the 42nd knockout and it was
33 seconds so Derrick Lewis has 14 Kos
he has the most knockouts in UFC history
which is insane
um but shout out to Derrick Lewis I
assume the UFC signs him I'd assume they
signed him right back up although I
don't know how much left for him but
again if you want Derek Lewis to win
yeah Derek Lewis not interested in
testing free agency I'm hoping to stay
here in the UFC I I think for Derek
Lewis it's all about not being the main
event put him on like this third or top
Bill you don't put up the top billing of
mink cards he doesn't want to fight five
rounds when there's no pressure he's the
most exciting guy he's doing it for
money I think he knows he's never been
world champion so give him fun matchups
and good luck finding that guy if you're
not the main event good luck Derek's a
[__] handful
uh yeah and a lot of it is money so I I
wouldn't be surprised if like it won
Championship or pfl came along and offer
him Stupid Money he's gonna go where the
money goes guarantee it he's a prize
fighter at heart and you'll talk about
belts being number five number ten
doesn't care he does it for money
that's Derek Lewis he's great uh Bob
Green Tony Ferguson
um I might be the outline here where I
do want to see Tony Ferguson fight again
this might be surprising you some of you
because Tony freaks is one of those
Staples in the UFC he's Ultimate Fighter
winner he won 12 fights in a row at one
point you youngsters have no [__]
clue but Tony Ferguson was debatably the
best 155er walking this planet Bar None
and then the fight with him uh khabib
just never came to fruition they tried
it four times for a reason just never
happened and then he got older
competition got tougher they tossed him
the Who's Who and the division Justin
gaichi Charles Oliveira Darius Michael
Chandler Nate Diaz and then you know he
loses five in a row and then this is a
sixth loss in a row so it's tough man
usually the UFC especially a guy of his
coward usually gives you four in a row
but when you're kind of a legend status
of
21st and they're going to give you a
Long Leash and I think they owe Tony
Ferguson what he's done the the
accolades that he's had he deserves the
Robbie Lawler treatment so his next
fight should be
well not not a not a top 15 guy not a
top 20 guy not a top 25 guy a guy we
know a name but he gets the proper send
off to do one of those highlight videos
for him and we know it's his last one
and that's what they owe to Tony
Ferguson so I don't think this should be
his last one but the next one should if
that makes sense you know it's [__] up
say this guy needs to retired you know
the media runs within everyone's saying
that no no a guy of Tony Ferguson what
he's rests inside that op gun the UFC
owes it to him to give him the Robbie
Lawler treatment they need to treat
their veterans and the guys like that
with a little bit of dignity and send
them off on the right foot fighting
Bobby green and going out on a
submissions not the way you pay your
tribute to Tony Ferguson so I want one
more perfect match up give him the red
carpet and we all know it's his last one
that's what they should do
and what he did he say uh he was saying
that um
he he blames Bobby Lee's ipoke as the
reason why he lost that fight he
basically says I know but that's what
he's saying here I know he had to fight
through that
and that's something that Bobby has done
in the past and he said that it was
going in a bad direction for Bobby so he
did that on purpose essentially that's
what he said on his Instagram
yeah yeah one more thank you one more
what else do you have on that card Kevin
Holland looked phenomenal yes even
though he's a black belt just his gym
must not cover dark jokes he's been
choked out a few times by the Via darce
it might be a mental block where he gets
in he's like oh here we go again just
doesn't do the proper defense and that
seems to be what happening when he
shoots in his posture's weird he reaches
so if you're a dark sky like I am that's
that's a darsh delight that's like when
he's reaching out like this and his hips
underneath them that's that's what sets
you up for our daughter so you're
thinking trading he works on that but
he's just giving up he's making himself
vulnerable to the to the DARS Kevin
Holland is a black belt and so Gracie
black belt for God's sakes
um so shout out to Kevin Han I like
Kevin Holland at welterweight I think
he's a force at welterweight we've seen
him at middleweight we saw him again Tom
zot and short notice Tom's at eight is
[__] lunch so and that's an upper
echelon middleweight so I I do think
welterweight's better for Kevin Holland
even though he stalked while he wants to
fight at middleweight I think
welterweight is where he can be a top
five guy middleweight not top five
I think Colin is Travis looter is he is
he Travis Lunar black but yeah you're
right yeah yeah okay
yeah and that is no punk either
but yeah great card great freaking card
the only kind of Snooze Fest you had was
Alex Pierre Yan which
again the writing's on the wall for that
one if yon wanted to do that he could do
that I think we might give more credit
to oxpiera because the knock on him is
is his grappling and Glover texture is
like I'm telling you dude this guy's
grappling defense getting good his
takedown defense getting good submission
defense getting good he showed it yawn's
no punk you know he wore yawn like a you
know young worm like a backpack Jana had
the body lock defend the rear Nick choke
for literally four minutes in the first
round which is why they gassed out but
now experience no punk but now
depends what UFC wants to do there's so
many fun matchups again it's gonna be
Alex versus uh Yuri guarantee it but
outside that you got uh racic who can
grapple to but that's a fun fight he's a
warrior you got Johnny Walker there
which is such an exciting fight I have
to see that fight
um you cry a lot there's so many good
fights for him there's so many good
fights
so the UFC is probably pretty happy one
for yondoon can you imagine if there's
another draw
I can see it could be a draw that first
round you could do 10-8 if you want I
would have scored a 10-8 but some people
argued today and then Alex won the
second and third so then you do a draw
two draws for yawn Jesus
but I'm pretty sure they announced Maga
Med and rakik right oh no Uncle Lev and
um
um we just talked about him Johnny
Walker I think oh is it Johnny Walker
you're a tough fight of Johnny Walker
but again
not mad at it someone someone's gonna
have to do it you know and that
divisions in Abu Dhabi that's a fun one
UFC's like come on Johnny Walker we got
John out of here now we gotta get a mug
of met out of here because Margaret's
the one who can ruin the party forever
everybody yes
uh then you had boxing as well I watched
it this morning I watched it last night
I watched it twice
ah
um I think the the questions were
answered as far as is Earl Spence the
same I said this on fire because I said
this in here but mainly find the kid
talked a little bit about it with Luke
Thomas who worked the fight Luke Thomas
actually got choked up talking about it
he worked the fight Luke Thomas and
Ariel worked together for the first time
and since they're MMA fighting days you
know
um so that's pretty cool uh shout out to
showtime for making that happen getting
those two legends back together uh two I
mean one a one b as far as journalist
goes into sports yeah they're both so
[__] good so that's exactly where
they should be at Luke looking dashing
there in the suit but um
Luke came on the show I told him I said
what one of the things
that need to be answered is is Earl
Spence the same after the two car wrecks
the retina surgery on his eye that was
answered he's not the same if you watch
General Spence before he he wasn't the
same guy bud has gotten better
um
part of me as I'm watching my I can't be
I paid for this [__] it was a it was a
competitive in any facet it was just I
felt yeah it's weird too I'll talk to
Brian about a fine kid but
I felt bad for Errol Spence like I'm
watching he's such a nice guy if you
ever met early such a good person both
of them are great people you see uh Earl
Smith's face he has he just has the
friendliest face in the world it's like
bloodied and nothing's working nothing's
working and he's a term named he marches
forward his combinations are filthy he
breaks you down everything's based off
his jab his jab was his world-class jab
one of the best Jabs in boxing history
not there getting countered left and
right he gets knocked down multiple
times he's never been knocked down
before it was just tough to watch not
competitive they'll do the rematch it
probably won't do that well as far as
pay-per-view goes because this was such
a dominant Victory
um it's different than fighting right
like
like Poirier and gayty poy got caught
anybody could lose that weight anybody
could lose that weight you can't say
Justin gaichi's light years ahead better
than Porey I'll watch that rematch that
that could happen the exact same way but
boy head kicks him that could go back
and forth Bud Earl nah man nine rounds
of a straight not competitive ass
whooping what a shame what a shame
I I don't think it's good how bad he
beat him I don't think it's good for
boxing you know because we would this
fight should have happened three years
ago but finally we got it we thought
they were both in the prime we realized
Spence you know the car crashes and the
eye surgeries taking its toll on him
he's just not the same fighter but we've
been waiting vying for this Vine for us
and it's just a lopsided one-way result
it's heartbreaking heartbreaking
yeah buds buds the Bud's the man
it made me sad I'll say that I saw the
post fight with uh Spence oh my God he
was just like a shell of himself it was
tough to watch the thing about biggest
fight of your life ever you you're the
number three or four depends whose
rankings you look at pound for pound
never lost never even been sat down and
remember these guys have known each
other forever dude like and what's dope
about them both of them Dope and also
one of the reasons they're not
like casual fan favorites they're not
the most entertaining or they don't have
a ton of Charisma as far as it goes on
the mic they're all they do is focus on
boxing you know it's all they do so
you it was just tough to watch pory has
the best he was like he walked in I
don't know if he saw us he walked in the
post fight press conference he goes God
y'all acting like it's a funeral he's
like take it easy it's a [__] fight
I've already won yeah I have kids I want
the greatest ever do it I have a
beautiful wife I got money you got my
hot sauce [__] off [__] all y'all you
know it's like this isn't a funeral yeah
somebody with his career like that could
go and what's dope is Justin gaichi
you know what Justin Gates and doesn't
pour a are the bud Crawford and Earl
Spence of MMA
all they give a flying [__] about is
fighting in their family they're the
exact same people
but it just doesn't play hasn't been two
car crashes and had retina surgery you
know so you get these guys and it's a
great competitive fight you could say
poor I won the first round you know and
then with Earl Budd you were you thought
you were going to get it but the point
is is these four gentlemen they're not
on Tick Tock they're not doing Tick Tock
dances they're not doing the trendy
thing all they care about is winning
fights and they're for the most exciting
Combat Sports athletes on the planet we
got to witness it it was great the bud
Crawford Earl Spence was not great don't
get it twisted that thing was a lopsided
[__] beat down and uh it was tough to
watch tough to watch in the rewrite's
like okay they're gonna do it and it
gives us up to Earl Spence yeah it's up
to the loser it was awkward and he can I
think he could change weights too or
something like that I forgot who let's
go at 54. if I'm Terrance like whatever
you need literally whatever you need
this was not fun for me either I beat
the [__] out of you dude let's do it at
174. I don't care man whatever it takes
to get you competitive so like have it
Crawford didn't break a sweat dude you
have a mark on his face I know he looks
so he looked amazing dude walked out
with Eminem do you know the story with
Eminem uh a little bit but go ahead so
bud I think on social media was like
yeah I'd love for a big time musician to
walk out with me but I don't have anyone
this week in the fight Eminem sees it
and go and Eminem's on Instagram Twitter
social media he's DM me I had a thing
with Eminem right so I know he's on
social media because when they were
doing that like kind of they're trolling
the UFC Dana White they hit me up to
blast it out you know so I did it spoke
to him insane one of the craziest times
in my life because I'm such an Eminem
fan but so by Craft coming out because
I'd love for a big musician I don't know
anybody you know Eminem sees it goes I'm
down you're my favorite boxer boom
doesn't pay him nothing it was a tell me
if you liked yes or if you if you prefer
the way they've been doing it or you
prefer the way Eminem did it I'm kind of
leaning towards the way Eminem did it
because whenever you know whoever it is
uh Meek Mill walking out
um uh what's his [__] one of my
favorite artists um sings Isis
um rapper yep rapper sings Isis
let me see I'll joining Lucas Jordan
Lucas walked out uh with Woodley
whenever they sing it's a nightmare
whenever they're actually on the mic say
like you're like what is happening right
now I can't hear they're like what's he
saying especially with a song we don't
know we're like this the Acoustics are
awful Eminem was like I'll walk out I'll
introduce them and you just play the
track yeah and it's out of dope the you
know the the Eight Mile song that [__]
was lit and then he was like the best
you know welterweight on the planet and
then you just play a song I thought it
was dope it's the way to do it
especially when it's Eminem
but yeah fun fun night of uh fun weekend
of fights man what a time to be a fight
fan this is why we do it man for
weekends like this I had such a good
time with the companion I got a little
down because Cheeto couldn't do it she
was my boy and he was moving he thought
he was gonna have some help with his
mother-in-law and she's so we're going
back and forth I was like let's just
stop dude I can hold this down myself
like we'll get you on the next one don't
be this should be fun shouldn't be
stressful he's like love you man got it
I'm like just do your thing take care of
her family and I was like oh man I to be
transparent me and Ben have only taxed
and dm'd I don't never met the guy in
person but I like his content his young
kid and aspiring kid in the space knows
his [__] I want somebody Bradley doesn't
know MMA at all really didn't know who
Mighty Mouse was for God's sakes so I
can't just do me and Bradley I can't
bounce actually then just me talking at
Bradley not getting feedback there's no
you know to be general questions
and I was like yeah we'll see how it
goes with Ben I don't know him I thought
about canceling it I was like let's just
not do it and on the day notice it's
impossible to get a uh get literally
impossible you gotta flight people in or
they just have to have nothing going on
which is rare of guys that you want to
bring in so I thought about canceling
and boy am I glad I didn't it was such a
fun it's the best show to do now it's
the best show that I do here but
nothing's better when it's Rogan Eddie
Brian and me which we're doing this
Saturday uh in Austin uh JRE Studios
um for Corey sandhagen Rob font
and it's a fight night
just give us an excuse to get together
yeah you know it's not even a paper if
you get to fight night baby but it's a
good one of course Santa hey and Rob
font short notice Jessica and Josh
Tatiana Suarez I'm more excited for that
than anything Best Buy in the card is
Jacoby versus Kennedy I don't even try
saying his last name
take no little break from chatting all
things UFC 291 in Crawford Spence
because listen I only recommended
products that your boy actually uses and
I use this one I reached out to them we
talk about happy hippo they just
released re-release restock whatever you
want to call it their energy shots
you're talking about the best product on
the planet mixed with energy I use them
several times a day your boy just pops
these shots all freaking day long all
right there the company can trust we're
talking about happy hippo you get the
nice warm bounce good mood feeling and
it gets you in the zone they got the K
dips you know I like to dip but this is
straight up Kratom dips there's
Wintergreen the Razzle Dazzle they're
fantastic but my number one product I
can't recommend enough from Happy Hippo
is their energy shots it's fantastic all
right it's my Hidden Gem I use it every
day every show stand up podcasting
working out their energy shots are my
absolute favorite we just stocked up
here you can save 20 off when you go to
happyhippo.com promo code is thick thick
with 3 sees 23 say 20 for Life share
with your friends your roommates your
UPS driver Postmates driver I don't care
who it is give the gift that keeps
giving give them some energy shots from
my friends at happy hippo and however
you want you want you want freaking gels
powders energy shots the high
concentrated uh shots we got it all
happyhippo.com only company I trust put
in this Temple happyhippo.com promo code
thick23 let's get back to the program
what do you got you uh okay so going
back to the fights you know so Stephen
Thompson you said decided not to take
the fight after repair missed weight
like yeah so for those of you living on
a rock uh pierra came in I think eight
pounds overweight not even close four I
think was it four yeah
but uh
this is uh Stephen Thompson's statement
one of boys 40. and like he loses this
one it's like you're back in the queue
you gotta fight these animals so
I I get it with with uh Wonderboy and
also the UFC doesn't give a [__] they
just it's an h and I'm I'm not saying
they should uh the UFC should pay him as
show money because he did his job they
did it which is insane that's the rumor
right now for Mike bond from MMA junkie
they didn't pay him his show they're
saying well he said he heard through
sources that he's not going to receive
it that's insane that's stupid he made
weight that's UFC's way of discipline
him for not putting the fight on yeah
but it's not on him though it's [__]
up man it's not right this should why
guys don't have this clause in the
contract goes if I show up for a fight I
make weight my opponent doesn't I still
get my show money yeah why are we not
fighting for this
I have no clue and he even mentioned the
last time he did that he took a fight he
lost against Darren till split decisions
yeah yes it's not good and he again he's
40 he's ranked number six or seven at
welterweight division so if you take
this the guy's way bigger and younger
explosive you lose this one your
career's over dude like another loss to
Wonder Boys a nightmare at 40 dude I'm
with Wonder Boy and I was like no no I
ain't taking that and he'll see goes all
right dude we ain't giving you anything
though he had the chance to earn money
and you didn't do it so
how these guys don't have the claws in
their contract have no clue
how their managers not fighting for that
if your manager's not at least bringing
this up you ain't [__] how about that
I'm pretty sure they're gonna have to
bring it up
that's so messed up God these lollipops
are [__] good not a sponsor they're
just delicious it's got actual sugar
though all right I like it no two grams
sugar per cat two grams carbs no sugar I
know how much carbs in
16 grams not crazy but not great not
great yeah and I fast all day this
definitely breaks the fast yeah well the
joy of calories
way to bring that up chin so next time
yeah whatever bro uh so this is Kevin
Holland's statement about Michael Kaza
after the fight post fight press
conference
is a good dude Aurora's finest name a
mean guy from Aurora
all the mass Shooters all right dude be
cool dude but outside that everyone's
good in Aurora
so the game has circled in the past yes
uh and seriously left him retired
commentate focus on your family you're
never gonna get a title if that's what
you were here for it's not gonna happen
you're already collecting a check but
not getting hurt so just stop you're a
really good commentator and there's no
reason to take brain damage so it's kind
of hard but it's very accessible yeah
pure assessment
guess is going I think you'd be
surprised so yeah is not going to give
up congrats uh to trailblaze to top and
his team Kevin's a hell of a fighter one
of the most fighter one of the most game
Fighters Combat Sports I know this was
very challenging upon the face coming
off almost two-year Lafayette nightmare
I've never said no to a fight that's why
you left quiesa I'll dust myself off get
back in the gym and get back to work and
work on [__] darsta fans
you said that's like the hardest one
though right or that's one of the
hardest ones is that the one that you're
doing to Brian
yeah that's what I got oh yeah well I
got uh matron yeah in a anaconda they're
similar it's different setup but no it's
if you know what you're doing like you
can't get out there now once it's in
you're in a little bit of trouble
there's ways to defend it the best ways
to avoid it he
issue is it's the setup that he's doing
his hips underneath him he's re when you
reach out with a guy with long arms like
Kevin Hall that's why he's so good at
dances I have long arms too that it's
that's a it's a Peach's Delight you know
oh so he's got to do that work on his
setup
yeah I mean what what
um Kevin hansain isn't necessarily all
wrong
I don't think any fires tell another
fighter retire but
and this is just a quick one on John
blockage she felt that he was robbed
from that fight a bunch of Thieves they
robbed me anyway thanks for all your
support
got the fan base man
bro you hugged him and did uh nothing on
the ground not a robbery close fight yes
but it was fine decision
not a robbery at all like it could go
either way this is the this is the only
time I'm gonna side with Dan when he
says this like can't leave in the
judge's hands
like you you got to go For Broke like if
you're trying to get a finish and it's
even Up For Debate you gotta go For
Broke he didn't go For Broke he went for
safe trying to solidify a takedown late
in the third round thought that was
enough it's just not these days like you
gotta try and get the guy into the
[__] you know the Dark Realm take him
out you have to
you think you'd learn after his last
fight
yeah
Beyond some tough spot he's 40.
divisions packed but at 40 light
heavyweight could be worse
you know at least he's not a
welterweight or 55 or lightweight or 45
or if you're 40 at that eight you're not
I mean game over but I like heavyweight
there's still work for him do and he's
talented [__] yeah powerful too
so just one more I think from the the
fight card so this is a Priscilla
cashiera and uh she fought and ran a
Maverick who took the fight on short
notice I think a few days notice but um
so she was apparently known for being a
dirty fighter like she tried to eye
gouge I think Jillian Robertson before
and then in this fight she tried to take
off
um random Mavericks top start releasing
them titties that and fence grabs here
he is fencecraft Fish Hook oil check
all that stuff and then you can kind of
see it here
so you should grabs her top right there
and pulling down
uh let me rewind it for me so I'm sorry
I was looking at the elbows okay
so
right now
that one's tough looks like the glove's
caught in it to be honest oh I guess
maybe if she didn't have this reputation
yeah I agree but uh yeah trying to
release them puppies them sweater
puppies yeah she's doing that for the
Bros back at home
okay dude not cool either way the fence
grabs and potential oil check all that
stuff yeah she's like the quarterback
for the New England Patriots he's like
the dirtiest quarterback and no one sees
it he's just like
like buttoned up white boy from Alabama
he's dirty as [__] oh they they showed
all I didn't know it until they showed
that he's doing like how is he [__]
dirty then show all you're like holy
[__] this guy's dirty as [__] yeah some
of those people out there I remember
there's someone in the NBA too or
someone in like professional oh yeah
there's somebody in the guy that just
kept [__] people yeah him in the nuts
like tons of nut shots those guys are
hilarious
uh all right so apparently the
pay-per-view buys for Jake Paul versus
Nate Diaz
yeah he's not doing that great at least
not right now and Nate Dia is just kind
of like yeah people don't want to watch
this don't watch whatever
that's kind of a way of promoting you
know how when Rogan says I like I don't
have style or I don't care about I don't
have the style and have fashion but he
does that hit that saying that is a
style does that make sense so it's like
this all
movement especially with Nate him saying
if you don't want to watch it don't buy
it like that gets news like that's gonna
sell fights that's a very Nate Diaz
brilliant brilliant marketer definitely
in the news he said I'm ready for
everything I'm ready to go to war right
now I'm ready to be cool until it's time
I don't care no point in my career where
I'm not trying to scare anybody I'm not
trying to fool anybody if people want to
watch that'd be great if they don't
that's fine too that's where he got me
Twisted I'm not not in this gimmick
fight with him I only need him to know
that I'll whoop his ass I don't need the
whole world I don't need to be go
begging to watch don't watch
yeah I think for Nate and that's where
I think where Jake made a miscalculation
like Nate's like a true fighter to his
core so he's like I ain't doing all this
fake [__] like I'm just gonna go beat
your ass man like I'm not gonna do all
this [__] to sell the fights and throw
bottles and fake [__] he's like I
actually want to mess you up dude you
know so it's very on brand I think it
was a miscalculation by Jake I will say
this not a ton of hyped for the fight
yeah this is not what I expected at all
I thought there'd be way more but yeah
me too I think Jake losing his last one
really hurt him
Studio but
um yeah who how do you see the fight
going chin case
you think Nate beats his ass
Jen I mean I expect Nate because he's so
durable to last and then just his car
those first three is uh to me like this
fight's all pretty good off off the
first three rounds if Jake's getting off
and can finish him in the first three
exactly or Nate doesn't take you serious
but it sounds like he is uh if he
doesn't take serious things his kid's
just a YouTuber from Disney he can get
knocked out in the first three rounds if
it go if Jake's not having success in
the first three rounds it's gonna be an
ugly fight for Jake probably changes
trajectory as far as fight career
Nate's all about volume and a lot of
volume and pressure and like melting you
and so for Jake doesn't fought somebody
like that it's gonna be different for
him it's tough
it's good money on Nate as a dog for
sure yeah I'm leaning towards Nate but
of course Jake has power all the fruit I
guess see the first really two rounds if
Jake's having success and he's wobbling
him could get dice per day if and if
they don't take you serious if Jake is
if you if you're watching this fight on
Saturday and Jake's not having any
success in the first two rounds he's
gonna get beat the [__] up bad face is
bloody he'll be a meme you know that
Bradley Martin wants to see
he could potentially break then yeah
yeah Nate will break you his pressure
and volume it's a disaster
he's not a One-Shot guy
oh not at all all right so this has
happened this happened during the uh the
weigh-ins for Crawford Smits and this is
Caleb plant slapping pass like a cat
really fast
here we go
so this is backstage at Earl Spence but
Crawford
yeah he smacked the [__] up Jamal
doesn't sound like he just kept it cool
and I heard from the coach even from a
Caleb's coach
not killed coach I think Jamal's coach
one of the coaches he said that Jamal
started it first he touched his face
earlier on Oh weird yeah so that's why
he kind of probably was like all right I
did it earlier so I'm not going to do
anything now and he did the traps got
dunk Lowe's
you noticed that yeah Kim has a great
shoe collection good dude
cool
yeah but nothing happened after this
thank God
yeah uh we already announced the magomed
uncle live Johnny Walker love that fight
rooting for Johnny in that one and then
there's also two more bookings it's a
fun fight and ige Bryce Mitchell's a
great one too
as for September 23rd fight night yeah
it's got to be
yeah fight night that's a great booking
um
this started happen recently too so Ben
ashgren he made
um
he made headlines on social media
because he looks a little bit more like
he's jacked he lost weight and got more
muscles here uh-huh right here there you
go if you put 20 23 verses 2019
so he did lose you know
some belly fat and got a little bit more
muscle but then after this he's uh he
said he the only person he would ever
come out of retirement for is Jorge
Mosby doll
and then mozzarella I don't know who he
went first but module posted this as
well still alive yeah with him knocking
out and asking and so the thing is they
both want to fight each other but Ben
wants to MMA Jorge said he'll fight him
but only in boxing oh no Ben ain't doing
that no offload boxing yeah
all right guess I'd watch that I mean
yeah if it was on me I totally wouldn't
watch it I'm not watching Ben Mazda
boxing oh
yeah it's a Mazda event uh
I hope it happens so they both get paid
but come on yeah so Hamza was in uh
England in Manchester and he got mobbed
by freaking it seems like hundreds of
people
I'll show you some of these clips here
I hope they know he was in there I'm
sure he probably posted on social media
so he's recording here
holy [__]
like Michael Jackson dude
so the surroundings car
and I'll show you one more here look at
that
that's insane check this one go back to
the comment oh my God go back to the
last comments
Jesus Christ
very famous it hasn't fought in Forever
he's just
he's here this one uh yeah go down so so
this person uh Uxbridge underscore
Marshall underscore Arts unscore Academy
okay for all the uninformed idiots
spreading racial hate in this thread
this is Manchester a northern
ex-industrial city in the UK when the
first wave of Asian immigrants came by
invited the queen he came to work in the
Mills industrial towns like Manchester
people in the video are the second third
generation
progeny of those migrants
they're as British and anyone with UK
passport they would have been born here
raised here educated here and work here
I can undersea understand seeing a large
group of caramel colored oh okay thank
God I thought I said camel oh no no yeah
I know caramel Colored Boys in one place
may be a bit overwhelmed but remember
you're just this good old fast race for
that as remember they are British lastly
the area specifically is known as the
famous Curie mile Curry mile has over
100 Asian restaurants on its strip now
unless Dave can make a killer lamb you
can soon after the business
I blame your weak fathers for nothing so
I became racial somehow that sucks well
because people like God can't believe
this is England now yeah just stupid
racist idiots yeah lame that BMW is
filthy in the front there the M3 it
looks like a station wagonish thing
didn't it yeah they have a M3 or M4 with
the wagon out sick
sweet alrighty
also in Manchester in October is going
to be KSI versus Tommy Fury KSI I don't
see KSI winning that one
he's probably the best chance
at Jacobs
um Tom if you're lost yeah that's what
I'm saying like Jake was the best one to
beat him he didn't like he peace yeah
yeah I would see I would want to see KSI
J KSI Jake's the fight yeah I'd love to
see that but this one yeah it's a tough
fight for KSI
good for Tom if you're just taking these
guys out he's doing exactly what he
should be doing getting more famous good
for him dude Dime Piece
this is
um interesting so zabit magnet sripov he
was on a podcast a Russian podcast and
he just basically said that USC offered
him if he would get out of retirement an
immediate title shot
but he didn't take it
he was just be completely over it yeah
but I mean uh title shot I forgot how
high he was he was probably like number
one he was up there yeah he was up there
and was sick of that [__] and became a
male nurse or some [__] something in the
medical industry yeah but yeah that's
pretty crazy shot yeah that'd be insane
he still wouldn't do it no do you follow
Michael Chandler I'm sure you do right
yeah on Instagram oh my God he's messing
around with this snake I guess he's
playing golf but
he messed around like hardcore
he's a country boy though he's not gonna
bite his shoe on the bottom
is it it's not a rattlesnake
there's no there's no rattle you'd hear
chin
sometimes
nah man
oh uh it looks like a rattler
this fool is crocodile hunter here
just thick little legs
he doesn't leave it alone knock it off
knock it off knock it off
it'll definitely be out of that Conor
fight no get away
just let it go leave it alone
leave him alone
let him go home
God these dude animal cruelty to the
fullest we're asking the animal to
create kind of shows me a way to go God
unless he Stomps his things ahead he's
not being too mean to the snake
I just don't understand what he's doing
I don't get why I do this adrenaline
junkie
look at this oh [__]
how was this video yeah so finally he
lets him go here it's pretty long but he
messed with it way too long I don't kind
of snake that is though
it yeah
that's the most action he's gonna see
because I don't think the counterfeit's
happening and now Conor called out
Justin gaichi and Gage came with some
fire I don't fight people take steroids
like he's like but he does want that
fight because it's a side fight of
course he does he's like a person say
that but top try for Conor man that's
the fight I would love to see really
yeah
you don't uh uh just in case he's turned
me down six times
I just but if you're if you're gay to
you do you want to put your name in the
Hat and like
do you say UFC's like all right you can
fight Connor
there's just no guarantee so you're just
waiting on the sidelines hoping counter
get this [__] together
it's getting a little I don't know I'm
such a Connor fan that's the thing I
don't think he's gonna fight Chandler
but so but there's no way Conor comes
back and he fights gaichi if he's not
gonna fight Chandler I mean he wants a
tough to fight yeah he does he or does
he just want his name in the headlines
yeah that's two
yeah and then of course uh gaichi just
said like just just pee in the cup
already that's how you're smarter the
car
and that's pretty much it dude those are
good dude cool
great freaking week of fights weekend of
fights this past weekend this this week
like I said I'll be on Rogan's fight
companion the original OG fight man with
Eddie Bravo Brian con Mr Joe Rogan
myself that's on JRE that's uh what time
does this card start at 6 p.m
6 p.m Pacific time so what is that is
that were they two hours ahead I think 8
P.M
two hours in so it goes goes down at
eight we might do the early prelims
because because Brian has shows at cap
cities which I might be at on Friday
but yeah Corey sanding Rob font Jessica
Andres Suarez uh Jacoby and Kennedy it's
a quality main card
three really really good fights our boy
Billy quarantilo is fighting he's always
a fun one
yeah there you go is that itching that
is also Jake and Nate but that's right
Jake and Nate is going down which you
will definitely be watching that
um yeah man Tune In You Got Jake Nate
you got the UFC fight night with my boy
Corey Santa Hagan Aurora's finest you
got the fight campaign with Joe Rogan
hey Bravo Brian count myself go watch
the last Cowboys fight campaign for UFC
291 available now with Ben Davis Bradley
Martin and then August 11th I'll be in
Phoenix for one night two shows only one
magical hot ass night uh August 11th
that's a Friday at stand up live go get
your tickets right now
Phoenix Arizona stand-up live Friday
show August 11th I'm in Omaha Nebraska
one night only August 16th Kansas City
will not only August 17th all right go
get your tickets thickboy.com that's it
be nice each other see you guys around
love you guys